[Música]
con nuestra primera invitada del día
vamos a hablar del congreso del partido
comunista chino que tendrá lugar este
domingo en el se espera que el
presidente consolida su papel como el
líder más poderoso de china en décadas
asumiendo un tercer mandato como
secretario general del partido Saludos a
raquelles ismara ella hace phd en Asia y
estudios de China profesora e
investigadora de negocios
internacionales de la Universidad
Autónoma de Puebla y directora del
observatorio de política china Raquel un
gusto Gracias por estar con nosotros
esta mañana de viernes aquí en directo
América de Francia 24 hablemos primero
de la importancia de este congreso del
partido comunista chino que va a tener
lugar este domingo que viene
muy buenos días Raúl un gusto estar con
ustedes y bueno en este caso como bien
lo dices es un congreso El veinteavo
Congreso de el partido comunista chino
que tiene varias temáticas importantes
ya ustedes abordaban de inicio este
tercer mandato de chillín no obstante
Pues bueno Más allá de esta pues
cuestión de de que se sucede algo
inédito desde Mao es decir algo que se
había de alguna manera establecido en la
Constitución de solamente dos mandatos
es algo que desde 2018
Pues bueno va a generar esta reforma
dentro de la Constitución China y en esa
misma en ese mismo tenor Pues bueno uno
de los puntos interesantes es saber cómo
llega a chillín a este congreso del
partido comunista donde de alguna manera
pues se dejaba ya Ver algunos puestos
clave como es el tema del Primer
Ministro y que sean quien se retira en
marzo y que también pues bueno en este
sentido saber quiénes van a conformar
esta pues camarilla alrededor de de de
del presidente como los hombres más
cercanos hacia el gobierno de China
sobre todo principalmente hacia la
temática de política interna no y junto
con ello Pues también la renovación que
va
cerca de El 60% de los integrantes de
esta asamblea
Raquel precisamente hablemos de las
políticas internas que ha implementado
en todo ese tiempo el presidente
hablamos o por supuesto de una de las
más importantes y la que todavía pues se
tiene un poco de rigor la política de
cero covid que se ha implementado en el
gigante asiático que ha costado pues
numerosas pérdidas de empleo y también
pérdidas económicas una
desaceleración económica por cuenta de
esta política de cero covid también el
empleo de los jóvenes que ha caído
considerablemente y estaba viendo antes
de nuestra entrevista que se reportado
protestas inéditas antes de este
congreso en China no protestas contra el
presidente de Pin Entonces digamos en
materia política interna que más destaca
y que es la importancia de todas estas
políticas que ha implementado
sí Fíjate que en este punto algo muy
interesante es como desde una ámbito
meramente económico como es este número
del 5.5% que está ha planeado el partido
comunista a llegar en este año de
crecimiento prácticamente es como la
piedra angular hacia toda la
sostenibilidad de la parte pues social
política cultural en donde como bien
mencionabas tú hay temas que si bien
desde la perspectiva económica no están
o pareciera ser que no están funcionando
al 100% o no le están resultando en esta
planificación al gobierno de pues
generar esta desestabilización
principalmente en donde en esta
población joven que bien tú mencionabas
que son quienes de alguna manera están
sufriendo más este golpe de de la
política del Cero covid en el cual Pues
bueno no solamente si lo vemos desde
fuera no solamente es esta cuestión de
todo el encadenamiento productivo que ha
generado la dinámica del cero covid sino
también anterior las condiciones
sociales y obviamente de inserción a a
temas laborales de estos jóvenes este y
y y chicas este chinas las cuales Pues
de alguna forma no están encontrando
estas oportunidades hacia algo que el
presidente ha apostado y que por ejemplo
algo curioso en este discurso que dio
hace un par de días dentro del comité
central que es enfatizar esta idea de la
sociedad que ya ha llegado a un punto No
de de Confort sin dejar de lado pues
obviamente la filosofía partidista que
tiene este el partido obviamente dentro
de China no en la cual Pues bueno el
Cómo insertar a esta nueva generación de
personas chinas dentro de una dinámica
un tanto crítica por la necesidad de
crecer a estos porcentajes anuales como
el punto o el motor o si queremos verla
si la gasolina que permita el generar o
el continuar este ge este tipo de
proyectos de empleo pero también de
incentivar sectores que son estratégicos
como por ejemplo hoy en día también algo
que se pone o se deja a la luz es qué va
a pasar con el sector inmobiliario que
en el cual el gobierno era tratado no de
generar como estos candados para
mantener algo que que este que viene
dejando saber desde hace un par de años
no o incluso el tema de las hipotecas en
esta población joven Raquel vamos a
hablar ahora de la política
internacional que ha mantenido el
gobierno de puntos importantes Como por
ejemplo la relación con Estados Unidos y
la atención
con Taiwán no tras la visita de la
presidenta de la cámara de
representantes estadounidense Nancy
pelosi Cómo está este tema
en ese sentido es otro de los puntos en
los que previamente a la a este congreso
se ha enfatizado muchísimo
en este en esta parte bueno nosotros lo
vemos como parte de esta política
externa o parte de la dinámica la
política internacional sin embargo china
hace mucha referencia dentro de estos
primeros discursos o declaraciones que
hace el presidente que sigue siendo una
temática interna no en la cual de alguna
manera este pues bueno no va a aceptar
estos desafíos por parte del exterior
obviamente refiriéndose Estados Unidos
con respecto a lo que es el proceso de
este reconocimiento o independencia de
Taiwán no como movimiento que en este
caso para ellos sigues
siendo una interna interna en estos
discursos el presidente Chicken Pink
sigue siendo alusión a lo que es este la
convención de 1992 y la idea de un país
dos sistemas no y y es curioso porque en
esta temática pues no solamente envuelve
a Taiwán sino también hace muchísimo
énfasis a cualquier situación que
pudiera suscitarse dentro con no en este
caso por el tipo de estructura este
gubernamental que que tiene también esta
región de administración especial y Pues
básicamente en un discurso sumamente
nacionalista en el cual este pues ha
hecho eco a todo el proceso que ha
tenido china en este caso desde momentos
clave con Mao hasta lo que son cada una
de las tesis o en este caso los
pensamientos en los cuales han aportado
distintos dirigentes como es el caso de
del shopping o en el caso de ellansemin
dentro de la construcción de la
filosofía este del partido comunista
pero sobre todo haciendo efans énfasis
de esta visión de estado Que
prácticamente en una integridad de una
sola china en la cual shilipping Busca
dar como este toque hacia este tercer
mandato de lo en algunos este aspectos
se conoce como el sismo